you can earn
1120 per day in profit not Revenue
meaning you're above the one percent
earning in the nation while you're still
in school number one you don't want to
sell tutoring you want to sell the
outcome of tutoring which is to get into
either a job that's going to pay more
when you get into a better school that
has a material difference on the network
the companies that recruit and so you
can a very real way tie the increase of
someone's test scores to how much money
they're going to make don't do
one-on-one do semi-private it's still a
small group setting they still get the
personalized attention but when they're
taking problems you can have them take
turn doing the problem versus teaching
someone on the problem you're just more
optimized for your time from a money
math perspective you charge 35 bucks
it's cheaper than the 60 that someone
would charge one-on-one but you have
eight people you're making 280 an hour
you do four of those hours a day you're
making eleven hundred dollars a day for
four hours of work
thank you